[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi,
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and welcome to Google I/O 2019.
We're here at
Shoreline Amphitheater
where there's a bunch of really
cool demos and exhibits and fun
things to do.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to take you on a live guided
tour of all the really
cool stuff here.
So, let's go and get started.
Oh wow.
Look.
So you can see all these
augmented reality flowers
on here.
Oh wow.
Look.
I got augmented reality
glasses and hair.
We got Flutter running on iOS
and Android devices and tablets
and everything.
It looks great.
And I got a free snack.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK.
Let's try this one here.
What's the temperature outside?
A perfect day.
Exactly.
It's always like that
at I/O. All right.
Let's go.
Guess I should see what the
latest news is from my bosses
here.
So it's really cool, because you
can use either a remote control
or a game controller.
And you can control Android
TV to play games, watch
YouTube videos, and
see what's going on.
Experiments with Google.
So what we're
doing here is we've
got a machine learning
algorithm that's been
trained with animal sounds.
And the more accurately
you can make them,
the faster your little tractor
drives around the track here.
This is so much fun.
Woof, woof, woof, woof.
How was your experiment?
Awesome.
All right.
So here we're in the
gaming area where
we're seeing lots of
demos, interesting things.
These are all
targeted at developers
who actually make games for
Android and web and so forth.
So there's a lot of really
interesting news and updates
for them.
But what we should
do now is let's
go and check out what Stadia
has to offer for a demo.
And let's check it out.
So here we have
Stadia, which allows
us to play games on the cloud.
So what do we have here?
SPEAKER 1: This is a developer
tool demo that we have.
So what you see here is
we've taken this 2D image.
And we've trained a machine
learning model offline.
And we can apply it directly
in the game at runtime.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, I
want to see it walk around.
Can I play it?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, of course.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
this is using Shaders?
Or--
SPEAKER 1: It's using
machine learning technology
with Shaders.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Wow.
This is really cool.
Thanks very much.
All right.
Let's get out of here and
see what else there is.
Watch.
I can do this.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I can't do this one.
Well, I got something.
This thing is insanely accurate.
All right, you can check out
my poses on the screen here.
Look at this.
What a superstar.
OK.
So this is the Android
Auto area where we have
Android that runs in vehicles.
So what we see here is that
we've got actually a head unit
from a vehicle mounted here.
And then the phone is
projecting onto the screen.
And so the phone can allow
us to run Google Maps,
make phone calls,
play music, whatever.
It's really neat, because you
can do all the same functions
from your phone, but you
can do it in a nice head
unit mounted in your vehicle.
Let's go see if we can get
a sneak peek inside one
of the cars themselves.
Come on, let's go.
All right.
Here we have an
Android Auto car.
So this is exciting.
So we've got Google Maps.
We've got our phone.
And we can make calls with
it and listen to our music.
So yeah.
Let's get ready to take a drive.
So the Android Auto people
wouldn't let me take their car.
So instead I thought I'd
come over here and try out
this virtual moped
ride where I get
to ride through the
streets of Jakarta
watching a 360 video on these
virtual reality glasses here.
It's really cool.
You can do it on a 360 video.
When you're sitting
on a motorcycle
it feels so
incredibly realistic.
[GROAN]
All right.
Well, that was an amazing
whirlwind tour in Jakarta
on a 360-degree YouTube video.
And this is also a great tour
of the sandboxes at Google I/O
2019.
I hope you had as much fun
as I did watching everything
that's going on here.
And I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]